now what i want to call your mind back
to is this question right at the top
here
okay it was the laptop is depreciating
right so it was
hey do you mind getting that door for us
thank you it was a simple idea
of compound interest but in reverse
right if stuff is getting less valuable
rather than getting more valuable
same model but we just tweak it ever so
slightly okay does anyone remember what
did we cover
on friday what was the most recent idea
we looked at underneath this
had a special name it was a financial
idea right
with superannuation right it's like just
go back to the previous page okay
now the idea of superannuation is is
this thing here right
imagine if we took um this 80 000
earning just put it in just put in there
like wow i can save 80 000
every single year of course you can't
unless you're earning a lot
but this idea of something growing over
time and continually adding money to
we can do the same idea and think about
this in reverse okay
what happens if we get to that point
we're like okay i can retire now
what are you going to do that money
you've stopped working you're going to
start to
draw out of that right it's it's an
investment that you've already got
and it's been earning money for you and
interest and all that kind of thing but
now i'm like i've stopped working i've
retired
i need to draw on that now does that
make sense so we're going to do this
similar kind of thing we're going to
think about what happens when we turn
the plus
into a minus okay now when you're
getting repaid these things and here's
where your heading comes in
this superannuation becomes what we call
it's often called
an annuity right same idea right it's
money that's being paid annually every
year
but the direction of the flow of the
money has changed you're not putting
money in anymore
money's coming out to you does that make
sense now as you can see it's going to
be based on this idea but the numbers
are going to go ever so slightly
differently
now just like before we'll be best
served if we can think about this with a
practical example so i'm going to model
this on the practical example we did
on friday right we pictured the person i
think it was like robin and robin or
something from memory
they were putting money in and i said to
you hey how long will it take to save up
to a million dollars remember that i
think it was like 27
28 years some some lifetime career we
got two million dollars amazing
now i'm picking up from after that point
okay so we have the million dollars
let's write that down okay one million
dollars
that's been saved okay so now i'm going
to ask some questions about
what will happen when i'm now trying to
draw the money out
we've got some facts here so let's try
and um get this important information
down
we withdraw 75 000 on the first day
of every year so this is how much we're
actually going to use of course in
reality
right you're not going to draw it's like
i need 75 000 cash on the 1st of january
you're just going to do it gradually
yeah
but this is a model we can use which
will be accurate enough for our purposes
okay so i'm going to go 75 000
withdrawn first of january okay
um just as a point to remind you from
superannuation why do you think it
matters
when we actually withdraw the money
it's gonna it's it's gonna be for
accuracy's sake but more specifically
right
um have a look at the rest of the
question not only are we taking money
out
right we're taking money out it's still
most of it in the bank right or in the
superannuation fund so it's earning what
interest right so when the withdrawal
happens
versus when the interest happens kind of
matters it will make a difference to our
calculations
okay okay good question let's actually
talk about that now we've got an
interest rate
in the question right is it uh four i
think yeah four percent
four percent per annum now this question
this question
of when does it happen is crucial
because it will change the equations
that we get okay have a think about this
if you're the bank
you're the bank okay when do you think
would make sense as the time to pay
interest a year after you start earning
interest if we if we put aside for one
second that whole idea of compounding
daily monthly and all that
it's just a simplified version of the
situation we're just thinking about
years right
that money's got to be in the bank for
some amount of time before i'm going to
say well okay
i guess you've earned some interest yeah
so therefore what you can see is sort of
implied in this is that this happens at
the end of the year
i guess you could say 31st december if
you like right
so our order in our minds of what
happens every single year
is two things withdrawal first at the
start
and then interest happens at the end
okay now occasionally
things will be different they will
specify in the question they'll give you
more language that tells you when these
things happen
but for any other assumption we can just
work with this okay so
read carefully the question will tell
you what's going on
two questions that were being asked
what's the first one
will remain after 10 years after 10
years i want to know
what is the state of my superannuation
fund okay
question actually we'll answer it
maybe you want to ask it now and then
we'll see if we cause i want to know
what the question is anyway after 10
years right so that means
like is it asking how much it will be
after the interest
in the account after 10 years or is it
asking how much money after withdrawing
seventy thousand
thirty five thousand every afternoon
that is a good question um you're right
we will come to it but i want you all to
think about that actually actively
when we say after 10 years at what point
in the year
makes sense to be able to say oh it
should be this point or this point
just have a think about what that one
for saying we will come to it okay
just like with this salary going up and
the superannuation questions we did
before
we've got to establish a pattern right
so let's introduce some language some
notation that will let us
do that i'm going to call a of n we keep
using this
quite frequently because it's a useful
framework to talk about
let's let that be the amount at the end
of the nth year
that's messy okay so we're going to try
and get to
i guess the question will then be a 10
right that's the amount at the end of 10
years does that make sense
that's where i'm going to get to but
i've got a lot of work to be able to
establish
that actual equation right so i'm
actually going to start
nice and slow just like we did the
superannuation with not even the end of
the first year like before that
where do things begin a naught
at the end of zero years okay where does
it begin well we definitely start with a
million
right we definitely start with a million
but then immediately something happens
right
have a look i need to start using this
money yeah
let's imagine this is your first day of
retirement you're like well
i need to pay rent i need to buy food
right so i need access to that money now
so not just is there a million there we
actually have to immediately
subtract we have to withdraw some money
right so i'm going to take out that 75
000 okay what is a million take away 75
000
900 925
000. okay i'm just going to pause there
for a minute
and i'm going to point out that even
though this is simpler i'm actually
going to use this original line going
forward you might say why do that
like we can we can evaluate this one or
just use it well i'm going to have you
think about
why this is a more useful line as we
progress through the question
let's go to the end of the year now a1
is the end of the first year
so withdrawals already happened what's
the other thing that happens
interest gets calculated right that's
that's this guy here okay
so i take the previous amount a0
and then i multiply it by 1.04
do you agree with that that's the
original plus the interest that's the
point
zero four okay now i just said that i'm
going to use
this top line rather than the figure
that
it actually evaluates to let's see what
happens when i do that i'm going to get
this 1 million hanging out the front
did i write the right number zeros i'm
always skeptical um it gets an interest
calculation applied to it and then you
also have the
withdrawal right oh
and that also gets an interest
calculation
applied to it are you okay with that so
how does uh how is there interest to the
75 000 it's already how it does
ah okay good question now i want to
repeat ishaan's questions because it's
it's sort of
counterintuitive and especially if
you're like me and didn't do don't do
economics it's kind of like wait what's
going on here okay
um i think we would all be okay to say
925 000
if we multiply that by 1.04 you'd all
agree that's just
that amount it's grown is that okay does
anyone want to go ahead and work it out
962 okay now i actually don't care about
what that number is equal to because a1
doesn't matter to me i need a 10
okay but i can say well if that
what you say again 960 62 okay
that amount i can also calculate it by
looking at the
these components and multiplying them by
the interest as well do you agree like
these two are the same
so therefore the numbers ought to be the
same
except it is weird it is weird because
you're like hold on interest
getting applied to money that you don't
have why would this
be helpful well let's start to think
about what happens as we
progress yeah because what am i trying
to do like what was the point in me
doing t1 t2 t3
i was trying to establish a pattern
right i was trying to be able to say i
know what this is going to be
and therefore i can put it into here
okay now if i every single line
just get a number out uh 962 000 and
then 900 and whatever thousand
those numbers do not help me establish
the pattern it's these terms
that help me establish the patterns that
make sense